wollt ihr mal das befriedigende spieler
sehen ob ich es wieder mal ein wander
und heute gibt es ein ganz besonderes
video denn ich habe auf twitter ein bild
gepostet das seht ihr jetzt ungefähr
hier
da habe ich den frodo wer photoshop
bearbeitet mit meinen extrem schön
skills und dann hat ihr geschrieben
macht doch mal ein video und ich denke
mir ja klar
extrem schön mit vanessa das war das
intro die erste 1 sendung die ich
bekommen habe ist von einem youtuber
trio welches sage ich mal ein bisschen
erfolgreicher sein möchte denn es ist
noch nicht extrem schön und ich finde es
sehr mutig dass sie in der
öffentlichkeit dazu stehen und deshalb
herzlich willkommen
die apps was mir ja gleich mal aufregt
ich glaube ja dann braucht man gar nicht
mehr über arbeiten jetzt geht's los mit
dem familie an
wir fangen mit andrea ist unser
härtester fall
und wie ist print und tierwelt ich weiß
nicht jetzt andré vielleicht wisst ihr
das erstmal natürlich die augenringe weg
ja also gehört sich einfach nicht du
kannst kein geringe haben wenn du in der
verkäufer youtuber sein möchtest oder
wenn du nicht gefreut heißt denn das sei
keine augen eine haben schön wird man
als hatten der auch so eine komische
gesichtsfarbe noch schöner
ein händler
mir gefällt das nicht ganz so diese
falte lebensweg wir sind nämlich bei
extrem schön und nicht ein bisschen
schön ich bin ein künstler außen weg ob
man seine augenbrauen sind ja auch nicht
so perfekt und voller augenbrauen pochte
auch wenn wir sind hier im showbusiness
changes weiter oder man zieht aber schon
aus wie so ein camp für nicht so die
augen oder egal aber man schenkt es hier
hallo ich mach dich jetzt hüpft dann
gewundert so macht mich extrem schön es
noch besser
hast du brust nicht rasiert mensch jetzt
muss ich das wieder machen mit einer
haut wir müssen die manchmal machen das
könnte natürlich nicht sehen man ahnt es
dass ich öffnete das hierzu drüber
ziehen hier
wir müssen nämlich die warteschlange am
machen nehmen wir das hier so ein weg
wieder glück noch so schöne bank also
die bestrafung dafür
ja schaut euch den doch mal ein mensch
älter
er sieht aus als ob irgendeine krankheit
hätte euch bin ich komm nicht drauf
welche kann man die augen bisschen
größer man ein bisschen schade sie nicht
die puppe war mir schon mal vorher
nachher sehen
wow wow extrem schön
extrem schön ich lasse ich so du bist
extrem schön
schaut euch diese seien ganz kleinen
dingen
da könnt ihr euch bin mal was davon
abgucken
jetzt fragt ihr euch wäre es unser
nächstes opfer wen mache ich als
nächstes extrem schön
sie sieht immer super perfekt aus auf
ihren instagram fotos aber ich habe ein
bild gefunden auf dem sie nicht extrem
schön ist
babys beauty palace baby keine sorge ich
mache dich extrem schön
was ist echt dass kein filter drauf wie
sonst da machen wir mal richtig krasse
action also wir müssen erstmal die augen
dinge wegkriegen geht ja so nicht also
doch
ich glaube brauchen mehr wimpern
so kavai die nase muss auf jeden fall
schmaler
das ist also ein bisschen scheiße nase
guckt euch das an michael jackson und
ich glaube ein bisschen voller in lippen
wie lustig leute runde falten im gesicht
aussehen lustig comedy aber was wäre
denn babys beauty palace ohne ihren
julian co
er hatte schon so ein bisschen
durchgezecht die nacht dem müssen wir
doch diese die müssen jetzt erst mal weg
kriegen die augen
die augenringe
im weg so wie kriegen wir denn jetzt
deine stirn
yahoo
wir machen dich extrem schön
extrem schön wirst du musst hier alles
hätte so ein vogelnest schulter dieses
niki hallo hallo hallo hallo und es war
nachher angucken
auf jeden fall vanessa war kein frauen
aufreißer frauen auf reiser sieht nicht
aus wie ein menschen existieren könnte
ich weiß ja nicht ob ich das aufgefallen
ist aber ich habe ein t shirt an und
sektor trainer
und was würde besser passen zum rektor
trainer als
chris das würde ich tun und ich mal
nicht zu sehen
wir machen dich erst mal extrem schön
ok
hättest du mich schon kunst nun glaube
ich habe euch hat die folge gefallen
also mir hat sie auf jeden fall viel
spaß gemacht
und wenn ihr wieder so was sehen wollt
schreibt mir einfach chakalaka